escape with two vowels is it possible if
I'm done if I could only reach my no oh
that doesn't look good
[Music]
[Laughter]
what yes now excuse me I'm gonna I'm
getting out of it I'm getting out of
this up take that old man I'm escaping
I'm going running free screw you and
everything you care
hello guy to me after your [ __ ] get out
of here you're coming with me
oh look is that was that Bigfoot oh my
god oh good you missed me dick what are
you gonna do about it
oh nothing that's what I thought see one
more try yeah oh yeah holy crap am I
gonna make it impossible my anus not
even a little bit excuse me
Oh Dan let die and a card but die
give us thank you thank you I like it -
Murderball okay ready made it nope get
out of my way get out of my way - okay
just got to be careful about this okay
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you miss me dick what's that oh
you can't hit a target you can't see I
don't think that makes sense hair but
whatever wait oh what's that
impossible no I actually care for once
ah look at me look at me Oh fly fly fly
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] tricks on you EPIK
are we talking here
good luck with these I don't need your
luck get out of here
doesn't hurt get out of here am i dead
not yet I'm not flashing with my face a
bit more excuse me oh is that supposed
to hurt me get out of here boom get hurt
oh what's that
no I didn't have given though got a
glass sticking right out of the base my
neck nothing hurt bit back you I'll
climb up on you get out of my way yep
got it nail it nail it nail it nail it
nail it nail it nail it
Oh
nailed it did I lose anything important
don't think so
excuse me balls while I handle you oh oh
oh I love the feeling of balls all over
my face
z chef's control Z chef
control Z chef control oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god oh [ __ ] it Oh
Bobbie
Oh cartwheel into death I can feel the
life coming back into my legs oh I'm
gonna make it if there's an end
oh [ __ ] oh god it's going bad the
nightmares coming back to me okay
still making it don't mind my leg that's
perfectly normal
oh I'm good this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
liked what you saw and you want to see
more leave a comment in the comment
section below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye bye